magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman we're
going to start today with something that
i know some in my audience don't really
want to
accept
but when we deny
an empirical reality
we're really all the worse off there's
no advantage to denying an empirical
reality and the empirical reality is
that joe biden's approval rating
is not good and it's actually getting
down to
where donald trump was at this point in
his presidency and we're going to talk
about why we'll talk about the
implications and we'll talk about what
could be done to reverse it but
it is now very clear
that joe biden has a political problem
on his hands and as a result democrats
have a political problem on their hands
uh in terms of the numbers joe biden's
approval
has dropped below 40 percent for the
first time in his presidency according
to the real clear politics average of
polls now what real clear politics does
is it takes
uh a number of different polls
individually some of which might have a
bias like for example it includes the
rasmussen pole
which can have a
sort of a a right wing bias it includes
the ibd tip pole which some say has a
bit of a left wing bias etcetera and you
get an average and yesterday that
average dropped for the first time below
40
to 39.8 and today has recovered just a
sliver to exactly 40. and as you can see
if you're watching that's the lowest
that it has been
since the start of joe biden's
presidency
and if we ask the question well it's
common that sometimes presidents come
into office with a higher approval and
then it sort of declines over time
how does it compare to past presidents
and 538 does that for us and what you
see
when you look
uh is that
joe biden came into office with a
significantly higher approval than
donald trump about 10 points higher
and that has slowly gone down down down
to where they are now almost identical
at this point in their presidencies
biden and trump are now basically equal
in terms of approval joe biden's
approval is well below where barack
obama's was at this point in his
presidency
it because of 911 is dramatically below
where george w bush's was although
george w bush did ultimately squander
the high approval that came in the
aftermath of 9 11. uh joe biden's
approval although for a period of time
was higher than bill clinton's at this
point in his presidency it has now
dropped below
biden's approval is well below where
george h.w bush's was
it is below where ronald reagan's was
and if we want to go back further it is
also below where jimmy carter's was
uh similar to gerald ford
well below richard nixon and you know we
could go back further and and it's a
different era if you go back to lbj
kennedy and eisenhower uh it's a
completely different uh uh political era
altogether i don't know how much we get
from looking at those numbers but the
point here is joe biden does have a
political problem on his hands now
why is joe biden's approval so low it's
a combination of things first and
foremost uh it has been some time
since joe biden has had
what we might consider a major
accomplishment
um
relatively early on joe biden had the
covet stimulus package uh shortly after
that there was the dramatic roll out of
uh the accelerated rollout of covet
vaccines but then
joe biden got hit with the delta variant
then joe biden left afghanistan which i
believe is 110 percent the right
decision but the right was able to
weaponize it pretty successfully in
terms of saying it was chaotic and
misplanned and it said all the things
that it would have been under trump as
well but that hurt joe biden
infrastructure was done but it got
relatively little coverage and then now
there's sort of this lull and so i think
there's a couple different questions
that we could ask one in a vacuum
what could joe biden do to raise his
approval in the short term i did a tick
tock clip about this by popular demand
and there's a few different things that
joe biden could do in the short term
although i don't know how much they
would benefit him long term you know
we've talked about the student loan
forgiveness
there is no doubt that doing some
student loan forgiveness would help joe
biden's approval rating in the immediate
but would it really help them and would
help democrats longer term maybe maybe
not i'm not sure
something on decriminalizing marijuana
federally i think would be very popular
but could he get it done
um is a sort of a real question
what about announcing that the pandemic
is over and uh this question which just
three days ago was sort of like uh yeah
maybe
it is very clear that due to political
pressure and quite frankly fatigue with
the pandemic
numerous states are now saying we're
getting rid of masks we're getting rid
of masks in schools we're getting rid of
in some cases requirements for
vaccination to go to certain types of
businesses and my expectation is that
for political reasons
uh between now and march 1st which is
the date of the next state of the union
that joe biden is going to give i expect
it could be next week it could be on the
day of the state of the union sometime
between now and march 1st i expect the
biden white house to come out and say
we are now at the point where life can
really start going back to normal now
there's divergent views as i talked to
you about yesterday as to whether that
is a scientifically and medically sound
thing to do some say there's really no
more milestones to wait for if we don't
get a more deadly variant it's sort of
going to be like this for the next
however many years there's really
nothing else to wait for it's time to go
back to quote normal and let people make
decisions for themselves about their
level of risk the counterpoint to that
is that there's still a lot of people
dying as a result of the surge that
started a couple months ago it is not
the time to do it i think that there is
significant
uh
leaning right now within the biden white
house to sometime between now and march
1st take a sort of mission accomplished
approach make a mission accomplished
type statement
when it comes to covid whether it will
end up being the right thing or not i
don't know
but joe biden does have a political
problem on his hands and these are some
of the things certainly that uh
when it comes to covid are uh are being
considered and very quickly because
we're basically eight and a half months
from the midterms
what happens in the next six weeks is
going to set the tone
for what the midterm races are going to
look like in terms of what republicans
will use to run against democrats the
culture stuff for sure
but what else are they going to use and
there's this limited window now to set
the tone for that for what that's going
to be and of course we'll be following
what it is
i want to do a very important follow-up
when comedian bob saget unexpectedly
suddenly died um uh not long ago
i
and many others predicted
there are anti-vax people who are going
to say this is uh because of the vaccine
now of course there was no evidence of
that
and there's no evidence vaccines are
killing people it's important to say but
it was a very accurate prediction
and candace owens was one of the people
who made that prediction and it was
disgusting and it was irresponsible we
now have learned the cause of death of
bob saget's tragic death
and
it is head trauma per his own family cnn
reporting bob saggett who was found dead
in his orlando florida hotel room last
month died from the result of a head
trauma quote the authorities have
determined bob pass from head trauma
they concluded he hit he accidentally
hit the back of his head on something
thought nothing of it and went to sleep
no drugs or alcohol were involved
now completely irresponsibly as many of
you will remember
prominent
right winger
uh candace owens and others made
statements like the following and now
i mean there was no evidence for it at
the time now we actually have a cause of
death think about how disgusting this is
particularly if you are bob saget's
family
so
am i a conspiracy theorist or am i
nostradamus
the answer is neither i'm just not on
big pharma's payroll and i refuse to
peddle in their lives
and so to that end today i'm going to
point out another truth and it will
likely be deemed a conspiracy theory
until it's not there are too many
healthy individuals like bob saget who
we know have received their vaccinations
who are dropping dead suddenly and
unexpectedly with no further explanation
healthy athletes young students in their
physical prime the majority of the males
dropping suddenly and unexpectedly in
the middle of games from heart issues
now as i told you at the time
it is not
that rare i mean you know statistically
these things are rare but they happen
and i remember growing up and i remember
when the basketball player reggie lewis
died
suddenly and at that point there was no
hammer called anti-vaxx
so the reggie lewis death was not
considered a nail with which you could
hit
with that anti-vaxx hammer now they have
this hammer and they want to use it on
everything what we know for a fact is
that these people are being mandated to
take the vaccine and we know for a fact
that these vaccines come with a warning
that they bring about myocarditis
now as you guys know there are at last
check
three instances
um of uh myocarditis that have resulted
in death in the united states related to
the vaccines
and uh almost every instance of
myocarditis
resolves quickly and without incident
and it is in and of itself rare and the
risk of getting myocarditis from covid
is higher than getting it from the
vaccine but remember
if you've got this huge hammer and
you've invested a lot of money in it
you're going to be saying everything is
a nail the media is once again
gaslighting the public pretending that
to even take notice of this very
alarming trend is a conspiracy well it
is it is completely without evidence and
as far as bob saget is now concerned it
is not the case and it was disgusting
when she said it
it continues to be disgusting and um
they're not planning on stopping and
that's the thing you you have to be
ready
when they start with this stuff we
really need to be ready to say what
evidence do you have
that that is what took place here and of
course she had none and there is none
bob saget tragically
uh dying from uh from a head trauma
and um it is
it's just gross
that people like candace owens are able
to monetize and weaponize
this incredible disinformation and she
has a big following she's well funded
and has a big following and a lot of
people hear this stuff and they just
accept it let me know your thoughts find
me on twitter at dpakman we'll be right
back
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite
magic spoon lets you enjoy a sweet
delicious snack without the guilt you
can stick to your goals and still treat
yourself and if you don't love magic
spoon as much as i do they'll give you
all of your money back no questions
asked magic spoon is giving my audience
five dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman
there's an interesting new piece to the
joe rogan vaccine covid controversy that
i want to talk about and
it's it's sort of a common
endpoint that often takes place when
someone
makes a bunch of statements or allows
statements to be made and those state
statements are then scrutinized then it
turns out while these statements are
inaccurate they're potentially dangerous
etc
there's this common refrain which is
some version of
nobody should really be listening to me
about this topic anyway and that's where
joe rogan has reportedly landed saying
taking advice from him on vaccines
isn't a smart thing to do and while it
might be funny and it's certainly true
a lot of the problem comes from
this sort of like moral hazard type
scenario although moral hazard's not the
exact word for it but but some will know
what i mean
where
those who need to be told
that it's not smart to take their advice
on x
are people
not smart enough to realize that and and
that's really sort of what's at issue
here so let me back up a little bit and
remind you guys a podcaster and comedian
joe rogan has been over the last three
weeks or so
i've been under heavy fire for two
different sets of reasons one comes with
regard to
covet and vaccine disinformation uh
perpetuated by some of joe rogan's
guests with no disclaimers that what the
guests are saying runs counter not only
to the medical science consensus but to
the empirical realities uh of of medical
science some such
uh claims have also been made by rogan
himself and this led to one controversy
wherein neil young and joni mitchell and
others pulled their content from spotify
and protest spotify the kind of main
platform for joe rogan's podcast
separately but relatedly there has also
been significant uh backlash
against joe rogan for numerous uses uses
of the n-word on his program over the
last decade um
some
jokes and laughing related to sexual
harassment and sexual assault and so
that that's another problem today we're
focusing on the vaccine piece and
there's a new report from mediaite which
says joe rogan says people who take the
vaccine take vaccine advice from him are
not smart are not smart
um
joe rogan made his way back to the
stand-up stage tuesday night and
addressed the spotify controversies
according to the hollywood reporter
rogan headlined a small show in austin
texas at the vulcan gas company and
talked about the controversies um
speaking about the n-word he said i used
to say it if i was talking about a
richard pryor bit or something i would
say it in context
somebody made a compilation of every
time i said it over 14 years and they
put it on youtube and it turned out that
was racist as f even to me
i'm me and i'm watching it saying stop
saying it i put my cursor over the video
and i'm like four more minutes i haven't
used that word in years but it's kind of
weird people will get really mad if you
use that uh word and tweet about it on a
phone that's made by slaves
rogan then tackled the other controversy
the anti-vaxx
he says i talk s for a living that's why
this is so baffling if you're taking
vaccine advice from me is that really my
fault what dumb s were you about to do
when my stupid idea sounded better you
know that dude who made people eat
animal penises on tv how does he feel
about medicine if you want my advice
don't take my advice
rogan previously said dozens of
celebrities contacted him for covet
advice including aaron rodgers and ufc
president dana white so this is this is
the exact problem guys the problem is
people are not
uh smart enough to realize that they
should not be taking his vaccine advice
the the people we're worried about is
the point and that's why it's so
concerning right if joe rogan was only
giving vaccine advice
to informed people
it would essentially have no detrimental
effect you'll be like okay nobody
nobody's taking that seriously
he's also by the way kind of calling his
audience dumb which is interesting they
may not realize that that's what he's
doing i don't know
um but but this whole like come on guys
who would believe me
it's a very common kind of face saving
tactic for people pushing these
narratives but at the end of the day
it's really an insult to his audience
you guys aren't so stupid you would
listen to me right and unfortunately the
answer is yes a lot of them are
a lot of them are and it's evidenced by
the fact that dana white is coming to uh
rogan for advice
aaron rodgers said on other podcasts
when i got covered
i talked to joe rogan
and there's this entire echo chamber
that reinforces the idea that you would
go to him i think it was um
there's this um oh man there's this
right-wing trump-supporting podcaster
named tim poole who i guess said you
know he used to be on the left i guess
or something like that
and when tim poole got coveted he said
he called rogan so it's not you know um
it's it's not only that rogan needs to
let the audience know i guess it's not
you're not smart if you listen to me on
this
there's other people who are then saying
i'm also going to rogan for advice on
this stuff and that's why it's so
concerning now the the fallback of
saying your audience is stupid for
listening to you it's interesting for
sure uh and it i mean i don't know what
it i'm not sure what it suggests about
what joe rogan thinks about his own
audience
uh because if joe rogan is saying it's
not smart to take advice from me
he must know lots of people are doing it
what does he think about his audience
which is an interesting question as as
well but this is sometimes you know it's
it's a version of
when fox news gets sued for the things
that tucker carlson says on his show
the lawyers for fox say
carlson is an entertainer who engages in
hyperbole
he's not saying things that should be
taken as fact he's not a reporter
but the whole shtick with fox is
report opinions and frame and package
this stuff as if it is someone telling
you these are facts but when it comes to
the legal defense that's what they go to
alex jones we know that alex jones own
lawyer or lawyers when he has been sued
say this is an entertainer he's doing a
character here the things he says are in
character it's it's almost like they
liken it to you know when uh
i don't know
when uh when rufus sewell plays
a nazi in man in the high castle
that's not what rufus sewell believes
it's his character and like we all get
it when we're watching man in the high
castle but it's deliberately
uh uh kind of uh obfuscated when it's
tucker carlson or when it's it's alex
jones and uh uh joe rogan's using a
different version of that he's not
saying i'm playing a character he's just
saying it should be obvious that it's
not smart to listen to me about this
stuff but it's not obvious to the very
people who are actually going to listen
and say oh ivermectin or no vaccines or
whatever the case may be so a common
refrain
that often kind of comes at the end
of these controversies and it seems that
that's sort of where joe rogan has
landed
this next story is completely
unbelievable do you guys remember when
donald trump would talk during his
campaign
about how people are flushing toilets 10
to 15 times people are flushing toilets
10 times 15 times and we were wondering
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
that he's so obsessed with needing to
flush
10 to 15 times
we have now figured it out
and it is unbelievable
new york times reporter maggie haberman
writes in her forthcoming book
that trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
um
this
is is this the explanation is this the
explanation
uh axios reports while president trump
was in office staff at the white house
residence trump was doing this with his
personal toilet
periodically would discover
wads of printed paper clogging a toilet
and believed that the president had
flushed pieces of paper maggie haberman
scoops in her forthcoming book
confidence man
this adds of i love this language this
adds a vivid new dimension to trump's
lapses in preserving government
documents
uh habermann reports trump has told
people that since leaving office he has
remained in contact with kim jong-un
whose love letters as trump once called
them were among documents the national
archives retrieved from mar-a-lago the
news of white house toilet flushing
comes as the national archives has asked
the biden justice department to examine
trump's handling of white house records
so let's go back remember this
bizarre viral rant from trump about
elements of bathrooms and 10 to 15
flushes we have a
situation where we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers
and other elements of bathrooms
where
you turn the faucet on in areas where
there's tremendous amounts of water
where the water rushes out to sea
because you could never handle it and
you don't get any water you turn on the
faucet you don't get any water
they
take a shower and water comes dripping
out it's dripping out very
quietly dripping out
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
it's so insane because people have been
sanctioned for far less document
destruction than what trump did so like
there's a very real story here guys
which is
trump ran on
hillary can't be trusted with with
documents with information she can't
private email all this different stuff
and meanwhile
trump is
eating documents according to omarosa
manago newman trump is ripping up
documents which then have to be taped
back together
trump's family is using private email
for government business trump takes
documents to mar-a-lago which is
subsequently taken back by the national
archives and trump is sitting there
flushing the toilet to flush documents
down the toilet so when trump says
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
what it means is i'm doing it i am just
flushing wads of documents down the
toilet and i'm needing
he's he's uh really exercising the
valves by flushing again and again and
again if you wrote this into a movie it
would be like it's too much of a
caricature no one would possibly believe
the president is literally flushing
documents down the white house toilet
clogging it and then having to get staff
to unclog the toilet from the documents
it's it's unbelievable
now on the serious piece of this at what
point is it time
to actually look at charges
for some of this document related stuff
sandy berger was a political consultant
was the uh u.s national security advisor
for bill clinton for a roughly four year
period okay
he removed
four documents four documents and sandy
berger was
fined fifty thousand dollars
sentenced to two years probation had to
do a hundred hours of community service
and lost his security clearance for
three years
ultimately gave up his license to
practice law okay
four documents that sandy berger
inappropriately took with him and
you know we the intent may not even have
been nearly as as as pernicious as what
it seems that uh and insidious as what
donald trump is trying to do here
trump's flushing
documents down the toilet eating them
and ripping them up and taking them to
mar-a-lago
and it's not just trump there are other
people that were involved in improper
handling of records or private email all
of this different stuff at what point is
it time to say there have to be some
consequences here we'll have the clip of
trump
talking about
flushing toilets 10 to 15 times on our
instagram if you're just listening today
find us on instagram at david pakman
show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
democratic congressman raja
krishnamurthy who represents the 8th
district of illinois that's the western
chicago suburbs he's chairman of the
house oversight committee on economic
and consumer policy also a member of the
very important house intelligence
committee congressman it's great to have
you on today
hey thank you so much david same here
so okay i mean to start we we spoke
today about for the first time in his
presidency in the real clear politics
average joe biden's approval has has
dipped just slightly below 40 it's not
great it's lower than at this point even
where donald trump was at this point in
his presidency and that was not good
i attribute this to sort of a lull in
what we might call
major accomplishments to point to
what do you think is driving these
numbers and what would you like to see
the biden administration do
i think that uh
covid
inflation
and um
probably the lack of
progress on certain initiatives in
congress contribute to this
but obviously um as you know uh
elections are brought choices
and i think that uh uh we're gonna have
some stark choices in the fall
um and but before then we absolutely
have to do better in congress but also
hopefully we can see covid
decline and inflation come under some
control
do you uh as an individual who's up for
re-election every every two years
do you worry when the president's
approval is low that it will affect your
re-election
well i think that
the president's standing
definitely affects
uh
how different elected officials and
democrats
um
kind of fare because of the environment
that the president's standing will
influence
but i think at the end of the day um you
know voters also try to balance
local concerns
and how they perceive their local
elected officials performance based on
their own experiences for instance
to assess
you know whether to support that person
and so i think the same will be true in
this election all that being said
we need to make sure that the
president's successful when he's
successful everyone's successful
but to do that we have to make sure that
we deliver for the american people and
address their uh you know everyday
concerns right now
when it comes to something like the the
russia ukraine situation i mean i think
that
bad faith actors will criticize
uh the president and democrats no matter
what is done either as being weak or or
too uh
strong or not being friendly enough or
you know whatever the case may be bad
faith actors will have their criticisms
but
what would you like to see uh the the
the role of the biden administration in
the united states on the basis of what
happens there in the next few months
well actually i think that the
administration has done a tremendous job
of pulling together our allies onto the
same page with regard to
aggression on ukrainian
ukrainian borders
i think that
[Music]
what we need to see at this point is
more multilateral
coordination with regard to
what the costs russia would face were to
invade ukraine and that means agreeing
on a very
strong sanctions regime
agreeing on what we would do to support
ukraine if it is invaded
and of course
you know what do we do to give russia an
off ramp uh with regard to the current
crisis
if we can do those three things
energetically and in a coordinated
fashion
i think that
hopefully we'll get to a better place
but right now obviously is a very
dangerous moment
what what does your gut tell you and you
know you're on the house intelligence
committee but so so your gut and what
intelligence you've been presented there
there may be some some gray area there
but what does your gut tell you about
the the real objective here of putin is
this to to suss out how people will will
react without a real plan to invade
it's very interesting and
i had the privilege of
attending a classified briefing with
cia director bill burns who's a
tremendous public servant by the way
we had this uh two-hour conversation on
monday
and without getting into classified
details i think that what i can say for
sure is that
putin has a very emotional connection to
uh ukraine in the sense that it's almost
like a a maniacal obsession with making
sure ukraine does not further
um kind of drift into the western orbit
interestingly all of his actions since
2014 the invasion of crimea uh the uh
the presence of
russians and the don bass have further
uh pushed ukrainians into
uh the the embrace of western countries
the second observation i have is that um
i do think that
uh putin if he's just operating as a
rational actor and setting aside his
maniacal
kind of personal obsession with ukraine
knows that
all things being equal
he doesn't want to have a situation
where he invades and then has another
afghanistan on his hands just as the
soviet union did
30 years ago
and i think that
because of that
i do think that there will be a search
for
diplomatic options that allow him to
save face
even at the same time that he you know
kind of rattles the sabers
my hope is that his head prevails over
his heart
and that we can kind of
convince or persuade him that the costs
would just be prohibitive for him and
you know at the end of the day
he might
want to have on his tombstone that he
was the one who joined ukraine to russia
but the alternative could just as be
could be just as plausible which is he's
the one that lost ukraine
and so i think that's kind of the the
balance right now
is there uh
discussion amongst your colleagues about
the possibility that
in the the sort of using the ukraine
russia situation as cover that china may
see an opportunity to escalate
aggression with taiwan is that a topic
of consideration
it is um
i think there's two reasons why
potentially uh she
uh may not the the chinese premier xi
jinping may not move on taiwan right now
which is
uh a i don't think that
china is prepared militarily to invade
taiwan
and i my perception is that
they don't think that they have
enough of a military advantage
over the united states in that region
that's my perception that's how i feel
and then the second is he himself is
trying to consolidate political power
this year
in china with the
i believe it's the chinese people's
congress that's happening in september
or october
and so he's also focused on making sure
that he can
uh bring all the elites along to
basically um
rubber stamp
his uh
being in office
for longer than perhaps any other
premiere in many years
um a couple of other things and there's
really so much to talk about in terms of
inflation
um
similarly to gas prices where certainly
a president can do a little bit on some
of these issues but really these are big
structural systemic things that are
often global in nature
what can be done about inflation what
should be done about inflation
well i think it's a real issue and you
you don't have to go further than your
grocery store or your gas pump to see
that it's a real issue and anybody who
doesn't think so is denying reality
i think there are three things that
uh we as lawmakers and the body
administration can do to tackle this
first is we have to fight covid
and we have to make sure that
we see
a decline in cases here but also abroad
so david in that regard i'm going to put
in a big plug for my legislation and my
moves to really get the world vaccinated
at this point not just the united states
because if we see variant after variant
come from abroad including the delta
variant which killed three of my distant
relatives in india and then the omicron
variant and others come to our shores
it's going to wreak more havoc work with
our economy and lead to more inflation
so that's the first thing we have to
control covid here and abroad the second
thing we have to do
is
you know those infrastructure
investments which we approved in the
fall
have to be directed at short-term
logistical bottlenecks
that
kind of continue to hamper the supply
chain so just as an example
we should direct as much of that money
as possible in the short term to
modernizing our ports
to making sure that our rail facilities
are modern and
capable of handling the surge in goods
that's happened now
having pop-up inland ports and so forth
the third thing that we have to do is we
have to we have to
call a spay to spade and
note that some companies are engaging in
predatory pricing practices
um and on my committee uh the house
oversight subcommittee on economic and
consumer policy which is a mouthful
we launched an investigation into the
meat processing industry which
where four firms control more than 60
percent of meat processing and have
increased prices
uh by double digits year after year and
are seeing net profits go through the
roof
um and we and that the same thing is
happening in other industries and so if
we do do those three things i think it
starts to help
but really what we need to do is make
sure that we can uh take the disruptions
out of the supply chain that will be the
biggest
help at this point on uh to pick a
couple of those things i mean on
vaccinating the world when you look at a
world map right now
we're basically talking about africa
where there's the serious lack of
vaccines i mean even if you know you
look at south america there's you know
in eastern europe there's still fewer
vaccine doses but but availability is
increasing rapidly
really everywhere but africa as far as i
understand looking at the map so is that
the area that should be the focus
i think that has to be uh among the top
uh places that we direct our efforts you
know in africa
it's still i think uh under 20
of the continent of 1.2 billion people
are vaccinated
and
i bet you you know dollars to donuts
that the next variant if it emerges is
going to be from a place like africa
and what we fear is that the lethality
of the next variant could far exceed
omicron and still have its
contagiousness
and that's what we have to be really
worried about and i i i'm concerned that
we have a real blind spot here david to
this issue and that's why i and jeff
merkley and others are pushing very hard
for the white house to direct
more funds much more funds in this
direction uh because it's a real ma
really a modest investment compared to
the price that we've paid to repair our
economy and our health care system in
other ways
so what about domestically at this point
i mean i i have a feeling that due to
political reasons
sometime between now and the state of
the union on march 1st the white house
will likely do some sort of a
pseudo-mission accomplished type
transition to the endemic phase
statement and whether that's uh
medically prudent is a question that
remains to be seen but you know in
illinois jb pritzker has said it's going
to be time to start winding down
mass requirements we're seeing it happen
in california new york some places in
schools does that make sense to you
right now based on the data what are the
milestones we should be looking at
otherwise
um is an important question
i think that
to some degree it makes sense to wind
down some of these mandates because at
the end of the day
we are seeing
a rapid decline in covid cases
and
i think there's a lot of public pressure
as well to
start to wind down some of those
mandates however we have to be prudent
about that because especially in schools
and other places where a lot of people
are yet to be vaccinated or ineligible
to be vaccinated
we just have to be cautious
and so
i think that
striking that balance is extremely
important right now
but i think that at the end of the day
we have to stick to the science david we
can't just
um wish this pandemic away we're going
to have to be very cautious because look
we all want to keep the schools open we
all want to keep businesses open we want
the economy to stay open and we cannot
ever go into lockdown so to prevent that
we have to take these very
basic precautions such as mass wearing
masks distancing and so forth
okay last thing i want to talk about
nancy pelosi in december said no to a
congressional stock trading ban
in january she said she's open to it and
now she's actually supporting it can you
talk a little bit about your thoughts on
the issue but also
the specifics of how such a ban might
work in the sense that a ban on making
trades of individual stocks while in
office is a very sort of narrow thing
and how this applies to significant
others or family members how this
applies to mutual funds and other things
i mean what would you like to see what
makes sense
i think what i like to see is my bill
become law it's the ban conflicted
trading act is the main bill that's
being discussed right now
it has bicameral bipartisan support
which is unusual for anything these days
in congress
and it's i think the subject of
negotiations at this point basically
what it would do is this david which is
what we know is that the stock act does
not work
that is the act which basically requires
disclosures
of
trading of individual stocks and
securities but doesn't prohibit it
what we found is that according to a
recent report 54 members of congress
violated just those disclosure
requirements
but hundreds of others followed those
requirements but have created a
tremendous appearance
of
insider trading uh you know basically
people assume that when members of
congress pull out their ameritrade app
and start trading stocks that they're
doing so based on non-public information
they gain from classified briefings and
hearings and insight into legislation so
the consensus in the grassroots among
democrats and republicans is the current
system does not work
what my bill does
is the following it basically
bans or prevents or prohibits
members from trading individual stocks
and securities
allows them to remain invested and to
trade mutual funds and widely
diversified funds
it also
if people wish to trade they can do so
through a blind trust if they wish to
keep their stocks they can but they
can't trade them they have to hold them
for the
uh the time that they're in office
and at the end of the day um what we're
trying to do david is
we're trying to restore a little bit of
trust back in congress here
and when every story comes out
saying that some member traded fi you
know bought pfizer stop because they got
word that pfizer just developed a
vaccine
or sold pfizer stock when they just got
word that the pandemic is
actually receding
that just creates the appearance that
they're trading on insider information
and it erodes trust further so we got to
bring this to an end now would this do
would there be anything in this bill
that would prevent
nancy pelosi from saying to her husband
okay you make these moves because this
is this is what's going on and would she
be in compliance in that situation so uh
technically that would be a violation of
the stock act if she were to do that
but if this particular bill applies to
members and congressional staff i'm
definitely open to spouses being added
perhaps through an amendment to this
particular bill
right now i just want to see the bill
move
because i think we could sit here and
basically have a situation where nothing
gets done
because people want the perfect bill and
really right now what we want is a good
bill
and we need it fast and i'm really
pleased that the grassroots and public
pressure have brought us to this moment
along with mine and my colleagues
uh fierce advocacy in congress uh but we
need reforms right now david yep we're
going to be watching that uh that that
bill very very closely we've been
speaking with democratic congressman
raja krishnamurthy who represents the
8th district of illinois really
appreciate your time today
yes sir thanks so much for having me
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show all right my friends dozens of you
sending me this clip overnight of course
i'm going to mention it radical
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
green is very confused and when she
wanted to attack nancy pelosi's gestapo
tactics
she referred to
gazpacho gazpacho the cold
spanish
tomato soup and my reaction was this
woman is such a dumb bisque i mean
really it uh
let's
let's take a look at the video
um
you know much like trump flushing
documents down the toilet as we learned
about this morning
this is the type of thing where
if it was part of a if it was part of a
screenplay it would get removed because
it would just not be believable
here is marjorie taylor green herself
take a listen not only do we have the dc
jail which is the dc gulag but now we
have nancy pelosi's gazpacho police
spying on members of congress fine
oh man if you missed it here it is one
more time
which is the dc gulag but now we have
nancy pelosi's gazpacho police spying on
members of as alexandria ocasio-cortez
tweeted
this is what happens when you ban books
from your house
uh this woman has gone completely lentil
i'm sorry mental i'm sorry now i'm
getting all soup uh soup confused no i
mean listen it's uh
as a reminder the gestapo was the german
secret police of the nazis in third
reich world war ii era germany
gazpacho is a vegetable
tomato
cold soup typical in spain
um i like blending a cucumber into it
people care about gazpacho that i i
think you get a really nice not only
taste but also in terms of the smell
uh throwing in one little cucumber
persian cucumber maybe it really helps
but nancy pelosi i can assure you
is not enforcing any super-related rules
here on the floor of the house and it's
beyond these people are caricatures of
their caricatures of themselves if you
wanted to ridicule someone like marjorie
taylor greene you couldn't actually come
up with something wackier and more
absurd
than her trying to say these
authoritarians with their gazpacho
it's you you can't it's too on the nose
it's there's no way to actually make it
any crazier and uh listen if you hire
stupid people to represent you in the
house of representatives you're gonna
get stupid gaffes and that's exactly
what we're getting and she's a joke and
she will almost certainly be re-elected
think about what this means about the
people of georgia who are going to vote
for her they're they're almost certainly
going to re-elect her to the house of
representatives
uh they're they look at us the world
over and they laugh they point and they
laugh and sometimes they cry
when they feel bad for us if they're in
an empathetic mood
absolutely humiliating uh we have
another follow-up by the way to do
yesterday i played for you this
incredible video of senate minority
leader mitch mcconnell
directly calling the january 6 trump
riots of violent insurrection this is a
very different approach than what the
republican national committee has said
the republican national committee has
really danced around actual serious
full-throated indictments of what
happened on the trump riots at the trump
riots as an attempted coup or a violent
insurrection they've played koi uh and
they have even censured adam kinzinger
and liz cheney two republicans who have
been willing to tell the truth about the
trump riots mitch mcconnell said it was
a violent insurrection and as expected
donald trump has actually lost his mind
over this he's completely triggered just
as a reminder here is what mitch
mcconnell had to
of congress and say use the word
legitimate political discourse we're
talking about january 6th
well let me give you my view of what
happened january the 6th and we're all
we're here we're here we we saw it
happen
it was a violent insurrection
for the purpose of trying to prevent the
peaceful transfer of power
after a legitimately certified election
absolutely
undeniably true and yet we knew that
donald trump was not going to like it at
the time that we went uh we
produced yesterday's show we didn't have
a response from trump
now we do and it is as crazy as you can
imagine donald trump putting out a
statement yesterday saying quote mitch
mcconnell does not speak for the
republican party he kind of does i mean
in a way he kind of does but okay mitch
mcconnell does not speak for the
republican party
and does not represent the views of the
vast majority of its voters that part
may be true
many republican voters have fallen for
the big lie
trump goes on to say he mitch did
nothing to fight for his constituents
and stop the most fraudulent election in
american history now it's a lie that it
was a fraudulent election and he does
nothing to stop the lawless biden
administration the invasion of our
capital b borders rising capital i
inflation
capital u unconstitutional mandates the
persecution of political opponents
fact-finding on the incompetent
afghanistan withdrawal
the giving away our energy independence
etc which is all because of the
fraudulent election instead he bails out
the capital r radical left and the
rhinos now what trump is very wrong
about here is while mitch mcconnell
correctly called the trump riots a
violent insurrection
mitch mcconnell is actually doing a lot
to get in the way of joe biden mitch
mcconnell and republicans are still
obstructing so much of what joe biden
wants to do so even while trump is mad
that as he sees it mitch mcconnell is
not interrupting trump enough mitch
mcconnell is doing what he always does
and that's obstructing uh trump going
back to the statement trump going on to
say if mitch would have fought for the
election it's like dude you lost what
can he do if mitch would have fought for
the election like the democrats would
have if in the same position we would
not be discussing any of the above today
and our capital c country would be all
caps strong
and all caps proud
instead of weak
and embarrassed
exactly what we expected from donald
trump
and we can only hope listen we joe
biden's approval is not looking good
uh the house of representatives for
democrats is not looking great for
november
the senate for democrats is not it none
of it is looking good
if we can
seize on anything to try to try
to get
mitigated disastrous results in november
it is republicans fighting like this
and hopefully some of them getting so
disgusted with this republican civil war
and infighting that they decide to stay
home that's the hope and of course we're
going to have to wait and see
whether that actually happens
okay
lastly
there is now a very
strange situation in the state of
georgia
and as a result
donald trump has put out a bizarrely lit
sweaty endorsement video where the
background is bright trump is dark and
glistening and looks confused and
actually opens the statement by saying
hello i'm president donald trump
i guess he thinks his name recognition
has declined and some people might not
know who he is this is this is what i'm
understand what this video is up until a
few days ago
vernon jones
was running against david perdue for
governor of georgia so remember david
perdue was a senator from georgia he
ultimately lost to john ossoff in that
special election on january 5th of 2021
and then david perdue said i'm going to
run for governor
vernon jones also running for governor
against david perdue drops out a couple
days ago and says i'm actually going to
run for uh representative for the house
of representatives it's not because he's
a great supporter of david perdue it's
because he realized he has a much better
shot of winning in the house of
representatives than he does at
defeating david perdue for the
governorship so the the timing is all
bizarre and trump says well this this
guy's a big supporter of purdue not
really he was actually running against
him and every aspect of this is just
strange the lighting is weird the
delivery is weird it has a sort of
hostage video feel let's take a look at
that hello i'm president donald trump
and when it comes to georgia's 10th
congressional district right i have only
one choice and the man's name is vernon
jones a very special person
he's an america first fighter who'll
never back down to either the
establishment or the radical left
few fought harder for election integrity
in 2020 than vernon and he's a big
supporter of a very good man running for
governor david perdue he has my complete
and total endorsement vernon will not
let you down
let's send a true patriot to congress
okay so there is donald trump and the
lighting is reminiscent of what uh
director of photography gordon willis
developed for the godfather uh just all
very very strange
and i just cannot get a straight answer
uh about the timing of any of this it's
all extraordinarily uh strange
and uh oh and i'm i'm uh and the by the
way the other thing is we're going to
see the power of the trump endorsement
we're really going to see the power of
the trump endorsement at this point uh
donald trump claims to have just a
fantastic record as far as endorsements
go and we're actually going to review
that record tomorrow in reality the
record is not really that great it's
very average and it will be interesting
to see what that endorsement record ends
up being uh in november of 2022 that's
going to be a big factor in determining
whether trump even runs or has a shot in
2024 do the trumpians and trump endorsed
individuals win in the november midterms
or do they lose and we'll be watching
those results very very closely we have
a fantastic bonus show today remember
the bonus show attacked by alex jones oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad crazy on today's
bonus show
by many economic indicators the economy
is strong
but voters are not feeling that it is
strong and that is another problem for
joe biden we're going to talk about that
on the bonus show
california is suing tesla
over allegations of discrimination and
harassment we're going to talk about it
and al franken remember al franken
senator democratic senator from
minneapolis minnesota
uh he says it you know it would be
tempting to run for office again we're
going to talk about the legacy of al
franken and the circumstances of him
ultimately leaving office
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access
by signing up at joinpacman.com we will
see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman